[Music]
before joes are adopted the pyramid to
model the kings of the first dynasty
were buried in highly complex mud brick
structures sunk in the desert and
divided into several chambers some of
these early royal tombs had an
extraordinary monumental character which
revealed the already complex level of
the society that built such tombs Djoser
was not only the first king who used
stone as a material for a royal tomb
building but also the first King to
build a pyramid it is also important to
stress that his pyramid represents
unequaled innovation in monumental
construction both in size and materials
used
Djoser's pyramid was built in stages
beginning as a square mastaba and
eventually being transformed into the
final six Step Pyramid it is unclear
with the process of building Joseph's
pyramid actually entailed but Joe
Phillip Louis who excavated the site
believes that the pyramid was built in
six different stages if one assumes that
this is correct then there was a major
enlargement every three years for Joe's
arranged for 19 years the implications
of building such a complex which was the
size of a large town in the 3rd
millennium BCE cannot be emphasized
enough indeed this would require tight
political control of the people and
resources of Egypt at an early period
Joseph's pyramid complex is unique in
that it is orientated north-south rather
than east-west like the Giza pyramids
and possesses a number of buildings and
structures which are not seen elsewhere
it is thought that Joseph's pyramid
complex was intended to model Egypt
mainly because of its north-south
division and because of the symbolism of
the buildings within this complex it was
the first king of the 4th dynasty
Sneferu who built the first true pyramid
his reign is particularly interesting
first neferu built several pyramids
before being able to attain the true
pyramidal form one can see
continuation from several of snipers
pyramid complexes to those at Giza
just like the Step Pyramid built by
Djoser
snipers first attempt at a pyramid at
Maidan was built in stages starting with
a seven step pyramid this was afterwards
enlarged to a pyramid of eight steps
later in his reign Sneferu sent his
workmen back to Maidan to fill out the
original Step Pyramid as a true pyramid
one of the new features of the pyramid
complex introduced in Maidan was the
causeway which was to become standard
for such monuments for reasons unknown
snafu abandoned medium and founded a new
cemetery in dujour there he builds two
other large pyramids known as the bent
and red or North pyramids the bent
pyramid started as a smaller pyramid
with a slope of about 60 degrees faced
with some structural problems with the
foundation the builders of this pyramid
had to adjust the slope to around 55
degrees since the stress on the pyramid
was too great and the structural act
stability as reflected in its pronounced
bend this monument was abandoned and a
new pyramid was started in North - were
around year 30 of his reign Sneferu
started work at the red pyramid which
was built at a much gentler slope than
the bent pyramid and was also made very
carefully from the beginning this
project resulted in the true pyramidal
form the paradigm of the Trouper middle
forum occurs at Giza the pyramids here
were built over the span of three
generations Khufu was the founder of the
Giza cemetery and the builder of the
first and tallest pyramid ever built in
Egypt at Giza
the ultimen pyramid complex namely the
mortuary and Valley temples was expanded
and standardized the pyramid cosway's
were extended to nearly one kilometre
and reached the Nile and the valley
temple Khufu's wall and causeway even
defined an area of harbours settlement
and possibly a palace by the river the
mastaba tombs that surrounded Khufu's
pyramid also represented a new form of
new crop
arrangement with its orthogonal design
giving the idea of an organized city of
the Dead with streets and a preconceived
plan the three different pyramid
complexes at Giza were enclosed by stone
and clay walls which are still partially
preserved around the complexes of Khafre
and Menkaure it is not clear how these
three pyramids were actually built but
it is important to notice that this was
the result of many years of
experimenting and pyramid building
note that Khufu was nefra son and as
such the workers and architects of the
Great Pyramid had already acquired
sufficient knowledge and skills to take
this leap forward after snafu it appears
that the technique for pyramid building
was standardized and step pyramids were
never built again in Egypt
you